kurz zuvor her ich will mich nicht als
winterreifen fühlen dieser vergleicht
mich völlig fertiggemacht ansonsten ein
weiterer grund zu sagen du hast dir
menschen ich hatte mal die die wirklich
naive meinung die hatte ich relativ
lange also die intelligent ist tollsten
menschen müssen unser land nein das muss
so sein sonst funktioniert das nicht
passiert ist so land der denker und
dichter und was war schon verbraucht hat
und irgendwie hat man einfach das derbe
gefühl seit fünf jahren da steckt das
funktioniert wie nichts mehr und dann
hast du nur noch politiker die sich um
die recht um die restliche streichen
streiten weil du kriegst keine mehrheit
mehr in dem sinne dann machst du faule
kompromisse dann
dass das funktioniert doch nicht und was
soll man denen dann auch glauben und
dann habe ich irgendwann entschlossen
also ich hab war auch ein bisschen über
das limit gearbeitet wie viele und hatte
dann die möglichkeit
von spanien aus das ganze auch zu
organisieren weiter es war ja keine
wohlstands flucht war schon einfach
ausgebrannt so machen zwei jahren auch
ein bisschen kraft gesammelt aber in der
zeit hat auch gesehen was passiert denn
da draußen im land und da ist es habe
ich das gefühl von spanien aus teilweise
klarer
ich kann mir die spanische regierung
nicht so viel sagen ich kann über den
lifestyle sagen ich befasse mich ja
nicht so mit spanische politik schon
allein wegen der sprachbarriere
adam ein crooner ja auch nicht so viel
machen können ich habe auch meine
lebensgefährtin elf wochen haben sie den
ins land gelassen das war ja alles total
verrückt
ich sehe hier nur wenig qualität und
vielleicht noch tatsächlich zehn
politiker wie früher wo man sagt 'die
sieht man denn glaubt man das ist egal
ob die bei der linken partei sind das
ist einmal die sie über die frau
wagenknecht also seit mai sind halt
einfach
urgesteine wo ich sage die haben es
geschafft über jahrzehnte
weitestgehend sauber zu bleiben und es
wirklich gut der ins auge
nach
der anstrengung
hier kann ich auch sagen der strauß ja
der hat auch dritten der haft heraus
wir stecken ja aber der hat halt der
wahrheit
der war was wo ich sorge wenn der wollte
konnte er
nicht erlebt ja nicht her aber ich habe
keine ahnung was da passieren muss ich
glaube es dauert noch lange und was
passieren muss ist dass mir persönlich
körperlich gut geht und wenn ich energie
habe bin ich gerne in deutschland mal
auch gerne meinen job und ich kann
nichts ausschließen aber das war es für
mich jetzt mal im werdegang wie gesagt
haben er habe bis jetzt war es alles
richtig ist auch die
lebenshaltungskosten kann man nicht
vergleichen da möchte ich einen haken
ich habe nämlich ein paar als
wirtschaftsjournalist so ein paar
capesize auch mitgebracht schreien und
deutschland weil ich dachte mir also ich
habe kein cabrio sowie man schaue also
ein paar stichpunkte mir aufgeschrieben
will stichpunkte spanien und deutschland
weil ich wollte das land ein bisschen
verteidigen als deutsche dachte ich mir
kann ich mache etwa die
landesverteidigung in spanien liegt die
arbeitslosenquote bei 13,65 prozent in
deutschland bei 4,9 prozent in spanien
ist es durchschnittseinkommen vielleicht
auch deswegen niedrigeren preise liegt
es bei
2147 euro brutto in deutschland ist das
durchschnittseinkommen höher bei 3000
sie mal 15 euro brutto und der
korruptionsindex tasche da sind wir auch
besser deswegen halte ich nichts dazu
sagen was fehlt ist die folgen die
privatvermögen für kopf und spanien
höher als bei uns die spanier sind
reicher als wir nur mal ein kleiner
datenpunkte hatte jagte und den sollen
wir retten jahresquote ja jetzt können
wir sagen wir haben eigentumsquote und
da kam ich da sagen die deutsche politik
was für die eigentumsquote nein sie tut
alles was leute kein anderer wir haben
können gibt's ja auch in spanien
menschen die kein privatvermögen haben
aber jetzt mehr davon dass ja aber wenn
wir trotzdem wir sehen das
durchschnittseinkommen ist wesentlich
ging an die arbeitslosenquote also 4,9
prozent gegen 13 65 prozent ist ein
großer unterschied ja und herr [ __ ]
nicht und ford macht jetzt die elektro
fertigung spanien nicht in salou eher
gut macht ja auch sinn weil die durch
sind das durchschnittseinkommen
wesentlich niedriger ist und vor den
kosten das sind und weil die
subventionieren und davon wiederum auch
die these teile spanien besser ist man
überhaupt nicht habe ich gedacht ich
wollte nur sagen daran erinnern dass ich
mal ein paar zahlen anschauen ja aber
man kann natürlich auf diese zahlen
allein kann man es nicht beurteilen weil
gibt natürlich wie misst man
arbeitslosigkeit und einer definition
etc ich hab nicht dass frauen besser
gesagt er ist witwer gottes willen aller
pakete gab es auch nicht zu dem die gri
wie bei uns das restaurant & co betrifft
dementsprechend nicht einmal er wollte
hörer verweist man kann nicht einfach
nur als rein schauen wo wir wo wir
besser rasiert er sie dann dazu wenn sie
die zuschauer ausradiert haben ja hat na
gut ich mir auch zum ergebnis kommen
gemeinsam einen punkt zurück an dem
vermögen wir sagen einfach mal wir sagen
immer also billiger sein reiches land
wenn reiche bürger schaut man stimmt gar
nicht italiener sind reicher die
franzosen sind reicher die spanier sind
reicher wir zahlen mehr in die eu
haushalt ein und gibt wieder auf profis
gibt den tagen der staatsschulden
diskutiert nur die italiener könnten die
stadt schon problem völlig problem ist
alleine lösen indem sie einfach die
privaten haushalte mehr besteuern wenn
sie in deutschland wenn ich ihn in
deutschland ich habe jetzt nicht über
die 10 millionen vererben 1 2 50 prozent
steuern weil wir nicht verwandt sind
wenn nicht die selben fall in teilen
hätte dass 5 prozent steuern das heißt
da gibt's riesenmöglichkeit für dessen
deutschland weniger besteuert werde
anderes thema aber prinzipiell aber ich
weiß der punkt ist ein anderer der punkt
von nur ja ja ich bin dafür dass wir
hinterfragen ob wir wirklich so reich
sind antwort ist eigentlich nein und
daraus abgeleitet die frage aufwerfen
ist es eigentlich richtig dass wir über
wiederaufbau von andere dinge milliarden
in andere länder verschieben die
eigentlich reicher sind als jedes
umverteilung von arm zu reich und dann
diese länder die mittel auch dazu
verwenden können um unternehmen anzogen
er ist dennoch auf um es nur noch mal
fest sein der spanien reicherzer
deutschland nein ich will jetzt nicht
denn ich kenne kein tier ist auf die ezb
sagt die europäische zentralbank hat
ganz offiziell es gibt ihrer spanische
privathaushalte vermögender sind als die
deutschen die frage der staat wenn man
diesen punkt eine frage ist ist es
schlimm der staat hätte was wir schulden
hat aber fahren sie mal entspannen durch
die autobahn wahrscheinlich auch eine
bessere infrastruktur und bessere
digitales netz deutschland hat innerhalb
der eu die schlechtes digitale man ja
auch mal so ist das also ist also im
letzten el castillo
am letzten bergen haben sich gut das
internet wo wir in bayerischen dörfern
schon keiner mehr dh sie haben besser
laden investiert aber das
durchschnittseinkommen die
arbeitslosenquote schlecht da immer ganz
geschlechter und mich noch ganz gut zu
verteidigen hier in der debatte ja ich
hab mich ja nicht so leicht geschlagen
für diejenigen der jetzt nicht reich
gehabt hat der kein vermögen hat ist
natürlich eine arbeitslosenquote von
13,65 und durchschnittseinkommen von dem
sehr gering das muss man schon sagen es
gibt ja entspannen viele schicksale wo
menschen wesentlich schlechter leben und
wo auch das sozialsystem nicht so gut
ist wie bei uns stimmt was wir müssen
auch ein grund dafür ist warum die
spanier mehr sparen müssen aber ich mir
geht es einfach darum hier stützen mal
hier und sagen wohin wohlhabenden geht
es besser aber in ärmeren geht
schlechter in spanien nächste stück
nicht bei uns ist es eigentlich so wenn
sie vermögen einfach anschauen die unter
den vermögenswert frauen italien
frankreich spanien ist eine viel
breitere vermögensverteilung unter
anderem deshalb schon angesprochen weil
die nicht mehr privateigentum haben an
immobilien zum beispiel weil sie mehr
selbst vorsorgen müssen der staatlichen
rente und ähnlichen aber daraus
abzuleiten wir sind so reich und müssten
deshalb allen anderen helfen statt bei
uns mal die autobahn zu reparieren und
bei uns mal das bildungssystem auf
vordermann zu bringen und bei uns war
den bürgern zu helfen ihr eigentum zu
bilden das ist die falsche
schlussfolgerung ging es nur darum dass
ich gesagt so schön gesagt haben wo wir
überall besser sind wir noch vielen
anderen dingen besser wir haben
rein gucken was interessant ist die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit versorgung so
hoch ist in spanien und bei uns diese
geringer und dann mal gucken was
passiert eigentlich in diesen ländern
die haben das gemacht was wir auch
gerade machen wir analysieren wie viel
zu viel das heißt waren viel zu viele
akademiker die hinterher keinen job
bekommen statt beruf ausgeschlossen die
duale berufsausbildung wird auch gerade
in spanien implementiert seit vielen
jahren und das läuft auch sehr sehr
gutes kann natürlich muss weiter
gefördert und unterstützt werden aber in
der tat er sagt zu recht die die länder
sind sehr unterschiedlich der eine kann
das sehr gut der andere ist wiederum in
dem sehr gut es bringt immer wenig uns
dann so pauschal zu vergleichen auch
wenn alles gut gibt es doch ganz andere
regionen sage ich mal auch von den
lebenshaltungskosten diese zahlen sind
sehr interessant ich hab sie nicht
gekannt
es geht nun hin sie bei alicante also
comunitat valenciana es wäre
schön wirklich viel ich bin fan und du
kannst in deutschland wenn du 300 du
dich erst mal dumm und dämlich und dann
findet man überhaupt platz wurde
freiheit mal so wie ich das gelernt habe
machen kannst und jetzt habe ich fünf
und nach die haben mir während ich das
das bemerkenswerte ist doch dass diese
kleinigkeiten anführungszeichen
tatsächlich zu dem lebensgefühl der
menschen so viele tricks unser land ist
ja doch nicht lauter aktionistisch und
so unglaublich durch bürokratisiert weil
wir alles und jeden absichern wollen und
das amt führt am ende dazu hilft die
persönliche unzufriedenheit immer mit
aber die frage ist doch mal eine ebene
kurs zu bringen ist wir haben ja
wirklich ein brain drain von deutschland
aus das ist ja wirklich es ist ja kein
einzelfall der was total exotisches
gemacht hat jedes jahr wächst auch die
zahl derer die deutschland 83.000
dauerhaft den rücken kehren sie können
über die zahl und das sind hier nicht
die transferempfänger sondern sind die
leistungsbereiten dem was aufgebaut
haben und die einfach nicht wollen dass
der staat ihn unfassbar viel wegnimmt
und sie darf er unfassbar wenig aus
ihrer sicht bekommen marodes schulsystem
erotisch straßen schlechte infrastruktur
etc plus was er auch gesagt das darf man
eben auch nicht vergessen er hat gesagt
sie haben gesagt sie fühlten sich jetzt
auch freier das heißt viele haben auch
den eindruck in deutschland müssen wir
verdammt noch mal ernst nähmen und dann
nutzt und auch nicht sagen zwei sind
knapp an ihm auch sehr stressig wurde
klar was ja haben doch den eindruck dass
in deutschland generell auf alle
lebensbereiche auch im denken eine
überregulierung herrschen und dann
fühlen sie sich vom staat nicht mehr
ernst genommen möchten dem nicht ihr
geld geben sich ihr geld nicht abreißen
lassen sozusagen namens steuer und dann
drehen sie diesem land den rücken zu und
dann ist ein fundamentales unternehmen
was gibt mir das auch ein fundamentales
problem ist ob ich nicht gewusst vorher
ganz ehrlich dann kommt dann nach zwei
jahren das finanzamt und fängt mit der
wegzugs besteuerung und ich denke ich
will noch mal für immer gekauft ich mach
doch weiter
das müssen sie erklären immer gesagt man
muss die reichen ihren gewinnen aus den
sie quasi hätten wie wehrführer heute
verkaufen würden aber will ihn heute als
die infrastruktur nutzen für unternehmen
in deutschland und dann also es gibt ja
auch gründe dafür oder dabei schauen sie
das ist ein wichtiger punkt da gibt es
ein ganz großes problem für viele
mittelständische unternehmen wenn sie
ihre kinder beteiligen an dem
unternehmen was man auch tun sollte weil
die nachfolge sichern und die kinder
gehen ins ausland zu studieren da kommt
das finanzamt auch und sagt lex
besteuerung und das ist ein massives
problem es heißt wenn sie also jetzt ja
keiner der glücklich oder unglücklich
aber potenzielle erbe eines britischen
unternehmens sind dann müssten sie in
deutschland studieren und können nicht
aber eine gute universität im ausland
gehen üblicherweise die us universitäten
der welt sind nämlich nicht in
deutschland das auch noch ganz los
vermag ich aber auch exzellente
universitäre zwei von den top 100 sind
in deutschland die sind beide münchen
alle anderen sind nicht und deutschland
aber die rwth aachen zb ist aussichtslos
ist nicht schlecht auch nicht in top 100
ist aber seine exzellenz uni normal dass
ja moment das was wir als exzellenz
definieren ich komme von weltweiten
ranking kann sich was wir selber machen
ist auch ein gefeiertes finden sie eine
einzige sache gut in unserem land jetzt
sagen eine sache wo sie sagen
das hier ist ja das bier sehr gut sagt
sich so schon andere dinge auch noch
eine spontane fragen die wir sollten so
tief drin in den themen nie aber sie
haben aber sie haben gesagt sie haben
benchmarking gemacht ergriff sie haben
ja nicht im prinzip ja und dann kommen
sie uns sagen aber er wird erster oder
unseren kriterien gut ist hat der po wir
müssen global gruppen und global ist
einfach so deutschland ist nicht der
platz wo ich jetzt wenn die leute sich
cora von vermaß kommen sagen wo möchte
ich gerne ansieht muss sagen da gehe ich
hin da ist die die umwelt in ordnung da
ist die schulsysteme in ordnung da die
steuerbelastung genau das ist es einfach
nicht es ist kein schlechtes land aber
wir sind drauf und dran ist in zukunft
zu verspielen so wie wir zurzeit und
seit einigen jahren regiert werden